so over here we have the graph of the
function y is equal to e to the x
actually let me
make that clear
so that right over there is y is equal
to e to the x this of course is our
x-axis this is our y-axis and so this
blue area right over here this blue area
we can denote that as the definite
integral from 0 to 1 of e to the x dx
and let's say we know in the future
we'll learn how to actually come up with
this number but let's just say we know
that that area is equal to e
minus 1.
so given that i have these other three
definite integrals and what i encourage
you to do is try to pause this video and
try to evaluate what these three other
definite integrals are using only this
information and what we already know
about definite integral properties
so i'm assuming that you have given a go
at it so you might first say okay let's
see e to the x plus two you might be
tempted to kind of decompose this into
the definite integral of e to the x dx
plus the definite integral of from
one to one so you could decompose this
from one to one of e to the x dx plus
one to one plus the definite integral
from one to one of two dx but you have
to remember if you're taking the
definite integral where your bounds are
the same this is a definite from one to
one this is going to be zero
this is going to be equal to zero once
again you could imagine that you're
trying to find an area of something that
has no width you're not moving at all
along you have no width along the x-axis
here so that was
that was pretty straightforward from one
to one your area is going to be zero
now let's think through this one over
here so here my bounds are different
they are the same as this as these
bounds right over here so i guess that
gives me a pretty good clue that maybe
if i can break this up a little bit
especially if one of these is in form in
the form of e to the x i might be able
to evaluate this definite integral so
let's do that
so the first thing i could do is i could
break this up as the definite integral
from 0 to 1 of 3
dx
and then i could say
plus the definite integral from 0 to 1
of negative e to the x dx
and then i can take the negative that
negative is really just a negative 1. we
saw that you could take that scaling
factor out of the integral so let's do
that so this is the same thing as the
integral from 0 to 1
3
dx minus the integral from 0 to 1 e to
the x
dx
well lucky for us we already know
we already know what let me just in that
same color we already know what this i
have trouble changing colors
we already know
what this right over here is
that's going to be equal to e minus 1.
so if you subtract an e minus 1
you're going to get actually let me just
write it out so we don't get confused
we're going to subtract
and
e
minus 1. and what is this going to be
equal to the definite integral from 0 to
1 of 3 dx
so that we just have to graph that to
imagine it
so
we're going from
0 to 1
and the function is at 1 2 3. i'm not
doing it at the same scale so the
function looks like that
so
this right over here is just this area
it's under
under the function f of x is equal to 3
from 0 to 1. so what's this area well
this is just our base our width is one
our height is three so this is just
going to evaluate to three
that's just going to be equal to three
and so we get this is going to be equal
to three
and you're going to have
minus e
just distributing the negative sign and
then plus 1
plus
1
and then of course 3
plus 1 is going to be equal to
3 plus 1 is going to be equal to 4. so
this is going to be equal to 4
minus
4
minus e and we're done we're able to
solve or i guess we say evaluate or find
the value of this definite integral
using only integration properties and
the value of this definite integral
now what about this one over here this
one is interesting boy i might have
different bounds here definitely go from
2 to 3
7 e to the x i have an e to the x minus
2.
and when you see something like this
especially if you're trying to evaluate
this only with integration properties
the the big thing that may or may not
jump out at you is that
e to the x minus 2 is shifted version of
e to the x it's shifted by 2 to the
right so let me let me let me draw that
so instead of this point being there
this point is going to be
there and so the curve is going to look
the curve is going to look something
like i'm going to draw my my best
attempt
my best attempt to do it so
it's going to be like there
it's going to be like there so it's
going to look
it's going to look something
something i'm trying my best to just
shift it over so each of these this is
going to be shifted
to right over here
so
there you go
that's e to the x
minus two
so we're going from two to three
and so what are the bounds now the
bounds are from two to three so we're
going from this point
right over here to three which is going
to be over here
just gonna be over
here so if you take this point you shift
one
and 2 you're going to get right over
here and what did we just do
we're thinking about this area right
over here well we shifted the curve over
to the right by 2.
this is the curve of e to the x minus 2
and we shifted the the interval of in
that we're trying to find the area under
we shifted that by 2. so this is going
to have the exact same area i just
shifted everything to the right by 2.
so
this area is also going to be e minus 1.
in my mind this one's a little bit
tricky you just have to realize that
this
that this is just a shifted version of
that and that we also shifted the two
bounds to the right and we already saw
that in one of the integration property
videos